[Applause]
Tennessee by - that's Tennessee's grant
Williams giving his team a two-point
lead with just seconds to go and
Thursday night sweet 16 matchup against
Purdue but the Boilermakers would play
heartbreaker going on to win in overtime
Williams the team's junior forward and
two-time SEC Player of the Year could
opt for this year's NBA Draft but he's
got a lot more going on as a much more
well-rounded player as our very own
co-anchor Dana Jacobson found out before
devoting himself to basketball grant
Williams was playing something entirely
different
reminds me of home to sit down a piano
it takes your mind off of things that
you might have been worried about you
may have a stressful day of basketball
you may have stress within school but
when you sit down and start playing
music allows you just calm your mind my
father loves music so every morning they
woke up they heard ragtime they heard
jazz they heard all sorts of music they
were the Williams boys with Grant being
the youngest of three in the home his
curiosity as a little boy enriched by a
family that always encouraged him to try
new things
grant came here talking mimicking
looking directly into your eyes trying
to determine what you were saying of
what you were doing he was observant and
just an alert little boy I definitely
describe myself as a nerd because I love
to learn it doesn't have to be academic
it can be any anything you can teach me
how to MIT now sit down and try and
learn with you well we never wanted him
to be regular we don't want any of our
children be regular we want our children
to be worldly men to make a difference
on this planet and Grant has done that
growing up in North Carolina
Williams competed in national chess
tournaments played several instruments
studied three different languages and
even performed in his high school
musical but it was basketball that
captured his heart
[Music]
as a high school senior he led
Providence day to a state title but he
still fell under the recruiting radar I
looked at him and I actually told him I
said you know you could be President of
the good kid club but with that said and
done I want to be hard on you and from
the first time he walked on this campus
he realized that now in his junior year
Williams has emerged as one of the top
players in the country his volunteers
were back in the NCAA tournament
as a two seed and in the regular season
Tennessee was ranked number one for four
weeks it was just the second time in
school history
the Vols had been atop the college
basketball standings
you could say grant Williams has been
hitting all the right notes talking
about leaving a legacy house for one
thing I said on my recruiting visit the
coach bars that I wanted to make an
impact on the school I thought you and
on your life and I wanted to be one of
the guys that you always will talk about
he's always said you know that he wants
to be the best he can be and that's what
you want somebody who simply has her
arms wide open say coached me and helped
me be everything I can be when you
realize his mom there's a NASA engineer
and his dad was a math teacher you
realize where some of this comes
wow yeah I want to be raised in that
family back in time I know he got into a
ton of IVs I mean just and chose
Tennessee because you know that was the
fit for him what about the man Scouts
what are the NBA scouts do how do you
rate the piano and chess again good for
the locker room